[Music]
bamboo is a material i've come to love
appreciate and admire so much because
whenever i'm riding a bike it's unique
nobody has it it's just unique to me
so you get a lot of attention for us
riding a bamboo bike
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is club nadal so i'm the founder
and ceo of boomers international a
company that manufactures bamboo
bicycles and accessories in rural ghana
so boomers is a social enterprise that
actually trains young people in rural
communities and employ them to make
bamboo bicycles and accessories so we
make different products from bamboo
using mostly school dropouts who
couldn't have had the opportunity to go
back to school and wouldn't have had the
opportunity to go to get for my
employment
[Music]
we have different types of bicycles city
bikes mountain bikes road bikes and we
also do the tricycles for kids
for everything that norma would would do
bamboo would do that almost everything
that a steel would do bamboo would do
that because bamboo is actually the
strongest plant you can ever find
because of the way the fiber has been
created this is what makes the bamboo
bicycle unique and people appreciate it
so much
currently we have about 40 employees
directly and we also employ another 20
indirectly who do the harvesting the
fiber that we use for the wrapping we're
engaging about 200 farmers to go into
bamboo agroforestry
[Music]
each record receives a very good wage
and then we also pay for their social
security and this should empower them
and should be able to make them happy
and that's why you come to the factory
and other guys are always happy doing
what they are doing because we live like
a family
between 2014 when we started going
commercial in 2018 we sold almost about
4 000 bicycles internationally
the goal is to produce between 5 000 and
6 000 bicycles a year we translate to
about 500 bicycles a month
my favorite part of the job
is
waking up every morning and realize that
you're not just thinking about yourself
but you are thinking about the entire
community
how to make the community better how to
empower young people
to empower themselves